the suspect is in custody this morning
after a woman was found dead on a cruise
ship in Alaska Princess Cruises said the
woman died on Tuesday following what is
believed to be a domestic dispute
it happened on the Emerald Princess
cruise line thousands of passengers were
kept on board for hours while the FBI
investigated the case Jamie yuccas is in
Juneau Alaska where the ship was docked
Jamie good morning good morning the
victim is 39 year old Kristi manzanas
of Utah once the Emerald princess was
docked here authorities were seen
escorting a number of people off the
ship
that's because the couple was traveling
with a large group according to
witnesses including the couple's
children Princess Cruises says the
domestic dispute occurred on board the
Emerald princess at about 9:00 p.m. on
Tuesday whoever was talking was pretty
scared because their voice is shaking
ruby plateau was with her husband when
she heard an announcement over the
intercom he said it was a domestic
altercation 1100 crew members and 3400
passengers were on board including Chris
seaman became apparent last night that
something serious had happened but we
didn't know how serious the Emerald
Princess spends the length of nearly
three football fields and has 19 decks
seaman says he was on the ninth level in
a room across from where it happened one
of the little girls from that room came
running out calling for help that her
parents had been in a fight she sounded
pretty desperate but the crew came up as
quickly as they could the ship departed
Seattle on Sunday for a seven day
round-trip cruise leaving Ketchikan on
Tuesday around 3:00 p.m. the death
forced the crew to divert the ship to
Juneau where it arrived just before 8:00
a.m. on Wednesday about six and a half
hours ahead of schedule the Emerald
Princess stay docked here until shortly
before midnight Alaska time after eight
hours of being stuck on board passengers
were allowed to be on land for about six
hours before the ship continued on its
route from here in Juneau to Skagway
Alaska for us it's a weekend for them is
the rest of their lives Nicole and Bryce
Beckstrom used to live across the street
from the family involved they say the
couple was celebrating an anniversary to
find
it was shocking passengers aboard the
ship say a murder mystery dinner was
taking place at the time this incident
occurred and while there was initially
confusion
they quickly realized how serious the
situation was the FBI says that today
they will announce charges against the
individual involved Nora